thank you
welcome back councilors and thank you
for those who stayed in attendance
you've now be seated
foreign
of the ordinary meeting of the gore
District Council did we have any
apologies
I didn't lose anyone in between meetings
thank you and Declarations of conflict
counselor conflicts of interest
none thank you councilors
we are going to move oh first up we have
a presentation from the lovely Folks at
lgnz and taitura can you hear us okay
I'm a bit correctly oh
so they can hear us they just can't see
us okay
I'd like to welcome Campbell Berry who
is the mayor of lower Hutt Joe Miller
who I believe is the chief executive of
lower Hutt
and Susan Freeman green who is the chief
executive of uh lgnz
did you want to take us away guys when
you're ready
oh we can't I don't know if we
foreign
oh we were on mute can you hear us now
we're gonna hit the kill fantastic so
I've just introduced you so we've got
Campbell Berry mayor of uh lower Hutts
Joe Miller who's the chief executive of
lower Hutt and Susan Freeman green who
is the chief executive of elgin's ear
take it away when you're ready guys
chief executive Susan Freeman green I
just wanted to First acknowledge how
tough the last few months has been for
for all of you missing a community
leader I know in these roles that
expectations are high and each and every
one of you have been on some pretty
significant other scrutiny over the last
three win wild as well and then that is
difficult
is quite richer than this
I was sort of appreciate and acknowledge
also some of the the movement from the
council and all of us were tuned in
through YouTube to your meeting just
earlier
if you'd look to look for that support
that is needed and to be able to move
forward to Australian
I acknowledged it
I just also want to say that in the
roles that we hold we all know
we all want to do what is right by the
I'm sure that you're all incredibly
conscious of that to be able to to again
move forward
so we are here to help and workers are
collective between Toyota algae and Sid
and the DIA to be able to get all of the
issues that are currently via into
a review and investigated by and in the
producer who will not only be able to
come up with Finance but also be able to
I hope offer a Pathways forward as well
before I pass it to Joe I just wanted to
say also that while I you you face a
number of unique income fixed challenges
to You are not alone when it comes to
councils going through these types of
those challenging issues and times while
I while I was the youngest of the year
before Ben stole my title of the local
party election but I have been around
for around a decade of local government
and I've got to say that these issues do
Arise at councils throughout New Zealand
you are not unique you're not alone I'll
be at their experience to pretty
significant media scrutiny on you and
from my Reflections what I can see from
those councils who have gotten through
that they have thought that independent
support and expertise to be able to be
outcoming to be able to trust the
process than to be able to enact some of
those recommendations and support moving
forward as well
so I absolutely think particularly with
the attitudes that I've included
half an hour ago that you're in a good
position to to be able to to do that the
only other thing I would mention just is
a process to support process to the
point of view uh
the momentum you currently have but
really encourage you as much as possible
to look at delegating
finalizing their terms of reference and
appointed an independent person to a
smaller group of counselors
to enable you to be able to move along
the bureaucracy of going through a
million process but I totally understand
that it's a decision for you I just
think that I've been able to jump on
that momentum is something that will be
quite helpful now I'll pass it over to
Joe
control
but you can change
students of the sector about the titular
that officers and lgn said are united
like you in wanting this situation
turned around and as one of the 3.4 000
people watching you on YouTube
the change will require every party
concerns to shift and you know that it's
incumbent upon you all to do that we
change
one party you can stay where they are no
one party can be captured by the past
and not able to move forward and
everyone working
and I just want to thank my barrier
knowledge how far you because I want 12
hours with the steps that you took today
the resolution that
it's given the degree of intense
Community politics that no doubt will
still be a play at War and we do want to
offer you know it's delighted to see
that recommendation on very
support both in terms of the terms of
reference but that's also a weekly
meeting to help you keep on track and a
very powerful contributions from
your mission
towards an independent review is that
the breakout that's required in this
situation and it's really important that
that sort of
achieve the desired out so yes people
need to understand how you got to hear
changes in control of those memories
actual governance and councils can be
very difficult and some people will be
more prepared for it than others but as
well as understanding how you've got
it's also really important that those
terms of reference I
management
a good governance culture to look like
for the future and we are really clear
that we love to work with you we suggest
working with a small group
the kitchen
it's over the literally the next
so that you can be confident that a
process is robust the
quiet bread
adapt and meets the needs of their Gore
community in a timely manner so as mayor
Barry said we suggest that delegation
that that's the matter for you there's
no reason
to Enterprise to every generation
so with that in mind
thank you Joe and I'm too really Echo
appreciation for the work and the
conversations you've obviously had over
the last
12 hours
and the commitments that you've made to
move forward
and also I acknowledge how how hard it's
been for all of you over the last few
months and it is so good to see
you've watched that extraordinary
meeting in the way that that played out
the street of the coming to each meet
and that meeting demonstrate that you
are
the account
s or hides yourself upon franchising
your people and understand the
importance of democracy
because as you know it is
very long to be
highly active
and you wouldn't have been able to
influence this decision as a council
although the loss of democratic voice
would have been a very real possible end
outcome for your community so we are so
glad you are not there
as Joe said we'd like to work with them
as a deputy mayor and the accuracy on
getting the terms of reference from me
and appointing a qualified reviewer and
then working with your Council
or report any recommendations that come
from there
also confirm what both Joe and mayor
Campbell have said
we do recommend that you could delegated
authority to the small group to sign off
on the terms of reference ultimately is
of course your core to do that and to a
point where
that would repeat momentum and get this
review underway as soon as possible
which we think is really important
ultimately we all want the same outcome
and you will give you and your community
confidence
to keep going forward in a really
meaningful way
we're happy to take questions
thank you actually but we know your
videos
you'll have to get update
yeah you'll have to get up the YouTube
recording
um thank you Campbell Susan and Joe for
um each of those talking points that was
fantastic I will open it up to
counselors for questions
um for the three individuals that we
have on screen
if we have any
councilor Stringer
oh thanks through his Workshop
the ongoing regular support how often do
you think that should be and what form
thank you
sorry
yes
um how long should that support go for
how often and in what form should it
come thank you
so can you can you hear me Susan
okay so the question was how often and
in what form would that support be
becoming so how often would we need to
meet and
um and gain its support
an Avenue for the rule of conversations
and then we convert you on what would be
useful we have a few ideas for a vehicle
conversation to take
of you in terms of what you think
I can do I want to add to that
no no I think that probably counts as
easy to take their conversation offline
I know that may for example be a weekly
chicken as well and a few of steps but I
would agree that the key thing is to be
able to move or some
review started because I think that
they're all enable all of those issues
to be able to go into a process
thank you Susan and Campbell for that
and thank you counselor do we have any
further questions
counselor got on
just as the panel um how you have quite
a lot of experience in this and I
presume you'll know how wide the review
should go and I just um wonder if you
had any comment on that
comment on how wide it should go
I think they were drafted a little while
ago in a different in a different phase
and I think we'd want to cover things
like timing the scope like
for you who the reviewer can speak to
you know what the confidentiality
Provisions around it
um
and I think
I think ways forward that
people can doable and become
the Canon will help you
thank you Susan thank you counselor
uh councilor Reed thank you Mr Mayor
just for the comfort of our rate payers
I wonder if you could
[Music]
um
just let them know whether or not there
is a cost to them as the rate payer for
having this review take place
I suggest the cost is less than the cost
of carry out of aquarium not as you are
what I can say is that there won't be a
cost for our support
was done for our members to foreign
having been in a situation without
is that you will try to reset well spent
and you will be very satisfied in the
future
thank you for that
thank you for that Council I think that
Joe
any further questions
all happy
so the recommendation there from uh the
team and I know that we've got an item
coming up around the review but the
recommendation was to
delegate uh the sign off for the terms
of reference and the uh appointment of
the reviewer to the mayor Deputy Mayor
and acting chief executive
would we be happy passing a motion to
that effect do we have any objections do
we have any discussion
councilor Dixon oh could you just
clarify that please Ben I'm unsure what
you were meaning absolutely councilor so
and to put into the form of emotion it
would be that the mere Deputy Mayor and
acting chief executive are given
delegation to sign off and create the
terms of reference with lgnz and titura
and to appoint the reviewer so that we
could operate at PACE on this
it makes sense that clarified for
everyone
counselor Reed I'm happy to move that
motion
and a seconder counselor Stringer do we
have any further discussion
just before we voted I'd just like to um
I suppose reassure Council that through
that process it will be my role to keep
you informed of the work that is going
on with Samir the deputy me and myself
with LG NZ and taitura
and you will be kept up to date with
both the progress of of it being
developed and the process in which it's
been developed in and all the Milestones
that that group
um will be working through I think as as
representatives from our gnz and taitura
mentioned the momentum is really
important to be keep going so we
appreciate the fact that you've got that
motion on the table today and the other
thing I think that would be
prudent of me to just remind you is I
will also be needing to put a report
back to you with respect to
covering the cost of the review through
an unbudgeted expenditure item so you
will be expecting that as part of that
process after that delegation is
followed through that I just wanted to
be prudent and wise and informing you
that this is that to happen as well
thank you for that Rex do we have any
further debate
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you counselors and thank you to our
guest speakers that was fantastic and
very informative and I thank you for
taking the time out of your busy busy
schedules to zoom in to gore and help us
out
thank you very much
let's get back to the agenda so uh item
number three confirmation of minutes
did we have any questions about these
minutes
uh we're looking at the
minutes of the ordinary meeting calendar
on Tuesday the 18th of April 2023.
no burning questions could I get a mover
that those minutes are true and correct
councilor Dixon and seconded by
councilor Phillips
any further debates
all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
confirmation of minutes of the audit and
risk committee meeting held on the
Tuesday 2nd of May 2023
did we have any questions
no could I have a mover from that
committee that those minutes are true
and correct councilor McDonald's
councilor Richard mcfail
any further discussion
all those in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried
item number five matoda River Crossing
project preferred option
did the report writer want to talk to
this at all
thank you worship uh no I don't have
anything to add to the report
but having to take any questions if
there's any
any questions for Matt on this report
councilor Havel
are you able to give a summary
background of where the people who voted
for either proposal actually lived
did they live in the district
three worship no I can't I haven't done
that analysis but I'm not going to pass
to our Communications manager
uh through the chair yes um we obviously
have to reject personal information for
public but I can assure you that the
majority of people that did take the
provide feedback were from within the
district
thank you Sonia I think you met thank
you councilor any further questions for
Matt
I will ask for a mover that the report
be received and then what we might do
after that is do what we did the first
time around and go around the room and
get everyone's opinion because it is a
very topical uh conversation so report
we received is moved by councilor Havel
seconded by councilor Stringer I will
now open the floor to debate
do we have
councilor Havel
we've received a report that that
outlines the public consultation that we
requested to be taken given that we're
really in an impasse situation
previously wondering which direction to
head
conceptually the notion of a bridge
appeals significantly to me the notion
of walking my dogs along the River Edge
I find particularly appealing and been
able to go over a bridge and come back
again
but that's my personal View and the
question is do I need to set aside my
personal view in terms of looking at the
wider view from an elected
representative point of view and I just
want to highlight just before I indicate
what my view is in terms of the matters
I've had regard to
the first one is cost and we're assured
that the um there is a potential for the
bridge to be paid for to a certain
extent and so we're really in the cost
neutral situation of a pipe under the
river or a bridge over the top so I
don't put a lot of waiting in that
secondly we've had an indication from
the the public where 63 percent of those
who
assigned or expressed an opinion
were wanting a pipe to go under the
river I posed the question where did
they come from and assured that the
majority of them were from within the
district so that's something to take
into account
the third aspect is risk under the river
we already know from the experience of
pipes being put under the river below
the Railway Bridge that there is some
complexity involved and it may not be a
simple process
similarly with the bridge there's
uncertainty about the consenting that's
required it's already been through a
consent process once and to the
environment court and there's clearly a
large number of people out there who are
opposed to the concept of the bridge
so the fourth Factor I've looked at is
the environmental impact
and in terms of that under the river
there's a construction impact but once
it's happened it's then neutral moving
forward and unless there's there's a
problem then there's no ongoing
maintenance but the bridge itself I see
that there is a strong social benefits
to be gained by having a bridge in terms
of access for people use by cyclists as
a an alternative to the main bridge
on the other side of that there's the
visual impacts of having a structure
across the bridge and turn across the
river in terms of what is at present a a
rural area there's the potential for a
bridge also to impede the flow of water
it comes down during floods and also
mindful of the damage that would occur
with any structures or Pathways or other
things that are within the floodplain
area
so where does that leave my personal
view I need to step aside from that
further the initial Bridge proposed was
poorly conceived with an inappropriate
design for its location and the entire
concept I think of moving forward on the
bridge is flawed both in terms of public
understanding and as tainted I therefore
favor a pipe being put under the river
thank you councilor hovel for that very
in-depth summary of your thoughts really
appreciate that councilor Paul mcphail
think you worship and think in case
you've said everything I wanted to say
so I just I go through the cost is one
of the key things
um a date ceiling and things like that
at the public are very aware of that and
we've got to be absolutely on the money
as far as that goes the public have said
they want the 63 want drilling under the
under the river
as it's a key indication that we that
the the council in the past has
and we perhaps haven't listened as well
as what we could and I think it's a good
thing that we've done I see that the
runanga we're happy to support the
various options which is a keypad we've
got to respect that
I'm worried about the environment
environmental work aspects of the of the
a bridge or whatever our structure
um I've got Fish and Game written down
here but I'm not too sure about them um
I've got the last thing I've written in
here is that we need a fast effective
outcome that's been going on for a long
time we owe this to the community here
to actually make something and do
something and and try and do at the best
cost we can so I I I'm going wrong with
drilling under the river
as far as my own personal
um looking at all the early outcomes
thank you
thank you councilor that was a fantastic
explanation
councilor read
thank you Mr me um
I I appreciate both um outlooks there
and I guess you know the conclusion is
that the public wants to drill under the
river so far I have read 217 of the 399
submissions and one comment I would like
to make is um and this has actually just
been in the last week I'd like to thank
the submitters because they were very
very thorough and the people it was
quite interesting reading the people who
chose to do the pipeline very black and
white yes do it the people who were
submitting in favor of the bridge issue
is was actually quite considered with
lots of in-depth views and I think we
also have to be cognizant that while the
majority want the pipeline there has
also been very very good submissions
from other people as well for that
social aspect going forward
um
if Matt and his team can come up with
some budgeting that is
will meet the job I think we are Duty
bound to go with the majority if that's
what the public wants
thank you for that counselor and very
well but I I think that I would love to
second that that the
we've had in this report some of the
highest interaction for a project of the
size and such in-depth submissions as
well so thank you for bringing that to
light Council I really really appreciate
that uh next up councilor Dixon and then
we'll go cancel the Stringer and then
cancel the nectar now
thank you worship
um
251 submissions preferred the pipe and
144 the bridge so we do have to listen
to our community
um and I think this has been a very long
process and it and I think that lessons
must be learned from this and we should
have
um we should have approached the public
and ewe at an earlier stage
so I I agree it's cost neutral
but it does have a short-term
environmental impact where the bridge
preps has a long-term one and there is
concern about flooding
I agree with Bronwyn the petition the
people have written in submissions sorry
are they're very good submissions and
very clear and very thorough
going back to another consent for a
bridge is going to be time consuming so
I'm I would prefer the pipe under the
river
thank you thank you councilor very well
counselor Stringer
no it's going to go now thank you
worship
um one thing I'd like to note is uh the
the consultation has been very good with
the public and the public has spoken
back to us and they have um they've
given us a strong indication of what
they want to happen and I think we have
to seriously take it on board on where
we go in the future
um
so personal opinions aside I favor now
going under the river and as we satisfy
the local marunanga
they're happy for that option to happen
as well and I think we are slightly
tainted if we're trying to push a bridge
through at this point from what's
happened the first time around where
we've got their opposition there to
start with so it makes a lot harder
thank you
thank you councilor councilman
ah go through the Mia karius met a
couple of questions please
firstly do we know what the structure of
the river bead is my big concern is we
start this and we end up
any Gap spending a lot of money putting
it across we might get a cost of 2
million or whatever but if we strike the
wrong material do we know is it a solid
rock Mass can we got anything to go on
and are we going to do we do a lot of
drilling first to find out what the
structure is and just comment on that
please
it's very worship uh
yes I mean
um
we if the council decides to go with um
drilling as the preferred option
um we plan to do as much investigation
work as we can to understand
the geology of the area where we'll be
drilling and we potentially can shift
the the pipeline alignment slightly to
try and
get the best
um
the best location
it is very difficult to completely
understand
the geology right across the the width
of the river
and as you're possibly aware there's
been other drilling projects where
they've encountered quite significantly
different ground conditions directly
underneath the river to what they found
on the on the banks of the river
um and so that is a risk
um
we will do as much work as we can to to
understand that
um but and I think this has been
highlighted previously ultimately
um we won't fully understand that until
we've actually done the work
um and so there is that that risk
associated with it
um
but
um yeah and then there's only a limited
amount of work that we can do to to
understand that unfortunately
thank you that answers my question
thank you councilor did you want to
speak to your opinion at all or would
you like me to go somewhere else and
come back
or is that all you would like to say on
the issue sorry
uh
because I'm a very frugal man in life I
I prefer certainty so I I think the
bridge
if you got that designed and even though
it takes more time I'm
even though the public are against I
think there's more cost certainty in the
bridge option and there's more chance of
if you need to put more pipes on a
bridge you can do it once you drill
under the ground you've got two pipes in
the ground and that's your total
capacity until you draw again so
um more favoring the bridge so I would
uh the option
thank you
thank you councilor
uh we have a few more councils left and
yep yep Chancellor mcphail and then
councilor McKenzie
yes thank you you worship um
obviously yeah
fellow counselors of trying to
transgressed most of the topics that
have come through
um in a wider view uh having been
involved in the previous Bridge
consultation or
discussion I can actually say that the
consultation document here and I totally
agree with what everyone else has said
that we have a pretty good lineup
of information from the community to to
give us an indication
from there uh cost yes we we're neutral
um
I do look at the fact that
we look around our country today and a
lot of bridges that are over rivers are
not over them at the moment they've
disappeared
um and uh I'm very aware that we look at
long-term and long-term 20 25 years
seems to be getting less and less when
we have these weather patterns and
weather bombs
um I'm probably on the side that the
pipe goes in it's uh under the river if
it's successful we get through there and
it um it fulfills our obligations plus
um puts us in the um
puts us back into the uh of what we're
actually trying to achieve so uh that
would be my opinion and it also
coincides with the fact that they're
public indicates that so I'd be sticking
with the pipe option
thank you councilor councilor McKinsey
met three-year worship met I have a
question that I've asked you before if
we go under the river those pipes are
still accessible aren't they for repair
in 20 years time they can be drawn out
is that correct
through your worship you said the the
plan would be to install the pipes
within a duct so that yes they can be
removed and and replaced or repaired if
required I guess it wouldn't be an easy
or straightforward process so we would
be doing everything we can to make sure
that we didn't have to do that
but potentially if there was a
significant issue we could could remove
them and repair them thank you Matt I do
remember the last time I asked you that
question you said you wouldn't be
getting in that pipe
um it you Australia I it totally makes
sense
between two points is a straight line
and we have the protection against
flooding so I'm totally in favor of
going under the river
thank you
thank you Council McKinsey councilor
guardine and then finishing up with
councilor Phillips
yes I um agree with um councilor
McDonald that um there is a fixed cost
with a bridge but
there is a Time Time cost and it's going
to be huge if we go with the bridge and
I think the public have agreed and going
underneath is the best and also watching
Gable the
cycling Gabrielle play out in the North
Island certainly
swung my decision more for under the
river and I think I'd go with one of the
river
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Phillips
I think you worship um
all along I've said that I would prefer
the bridge option
um knowing knowing that it gave us
capacity in the future to
uh express any pipeline across the river
two or four uh if there was an expansion
with the nerd town on these score
especially
with the bridge it's a known cost
um
with under the ground
I would prefer
for us to know what the cost would be
and I know it's impossible
but I just like to point out to the
right fail right here and now that if
the preferred option is
under the river you know I'm going to be
very mindful that every dollar that's
been will be spent wisely and correctly
and hopefully that the conditions will
allow us to put in an extra pipe for the
future
within that cost but cost Factor so
I just wait for the geologists testing
and hopefully that we uh we're doing the
right thing but
um
as I said all along my preferred option
was unknown cost was a bridge
I'll just now it's looking uh listening
around the table to my other colleagues
that the period option for them is under
the river and I just now wait until such
time as met gives us the reports and
to make my final decision
thank you thank you councilor and and
thank you Council laws uh for
all talking to those points and taking
the time to really get some in-depth
analysis to what your community is
saying and to what your values are
saying on this issue um as it's is
incredibly topical at the moment
I just want to start off by saying
um a huge thank you and congratulations
and a well done and anything else I need
to say to the staff members who have
been involved in this consultation
process it has been absolutely fantastic
I mean this report it's it's just great
um it's it's what we expect as elected
members when we ask for this it's come
back and I think you've even over
achieved here it's been been fantastic
so thank you for for standing out in the
cold and talking to the public thank you
to elected members who have gone out and
spoken to the public engaged their
Community
regardless of the the motion that is is
passed here today
I think as a community we can look back
and be proud that we all get involved in
a project we all had us say uh and and
we all got to have our voices heard so
so thank you very much
as for as for my opinion and my
community's opinion
um I I campaigned on on Back to Basics
so I think I've always wanted to go with
the simplest option
um I've had a huge amount of people come
and see me in my office to talk about
the bridge which is just fantastic it
makes my job a lot easier
I've had probably about what this
um what this outcome has provided of
about about 70 30 in terms of under the
river versus bridge I hear what people
are saying around the bridge uh around
it being a full loop around it being
socially impactful I but on the other
hand I also hear how just get on with
that go under the river
um councilor hovel brought up around
environment court before I I can't
fathom that we wouldn't if we went with
a bridge option end up an environment
court again that's a real fear of mine
it adds to adds to more cost
um for all of us around the table landed
wider in the community
with that I wanted to make it acutely
aware and I know that Matt's touched on
it before that the the row bridge that
we have in Gore and the rail Bridge are
heading towards the end of their life
and will need to be replaced in the near
future I believe that Matt said they
have about 20 to 30 years left we've all
seen what Devastation and Destruction
has done to
um the likes of Hawke's Bay and further
north
so I think that while it sounds like uh
the underground option may be the
preferred option today the thoughts of a
bridge may not be dashed we're going to
have to look in the future definitely in
my lifetime uh at what a new road bridge
is going to look like what a new rail
bridge is going to look like and at that
time there's plenty of opportunity to
put a cycle and walkway across there and
also to cancel the Phillips point
to add more pipes if we need to
hopefully we don't need them before we
can replace that bridge and I totally
acknowledge those points
so if there's no further discussion I'm
not going to allow comment from the
public I'm afraid sorry but I will
um
I I will put the motion of the report be
received first uh so all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
and from what I'm picking up from from
elected members I will ask for a mover
that the matoda river crossing project
that the council resolved to focus on
getting the pipeline across the river by
drilling underneath it could I get a
mover
councilor Paul mcphail seconded by
councilor guardine do we have any
further comment on the Motions on the
table counselor Reed
could I just refer the public to the
fact that the main bridge is nothing to
do with the gore Council because while I
was reading the submissions there were a
lot of people who really thought that we
should be hanging pipes off the bridge
both Bridges actually in both of those
bridges are not under air control
thank you
thank you Council reading and not to not
to argue against that point but there
are further discussions to be had when
that bridge gets replaced and I'm sure
the council will be involved in that but
totally agree that it's it's not under
our preview do we have any further
discussion
may I asked the effort members are
against this motion that they feel
comfortable voting against it that is
your right as an elected member so don't
feel pressured in needing it to be
unanimous
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
councilor Phillips would you like that
recorded or not
thank you the motion is carried by down
counselors and thank you to the
community and staff
oh yes I just to see you just made me
aware that I missed Point number four
whether we have any urgent late business
I just have and I'll pass it out to
staff as well I just have a late urgent
item around the matoda transfer station
and the Manning of that it is urgent
because their shifts are coming to an
end in the next few weeks before the
next council meeting and would like an
indication of whether we support that or
um don't so I think all the link to
members have a copy I will just
circulate that with
oh I would just say oh can I I'm happy
to move that to work can I get a second
to add that to the agenda
councilor Havel um I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye and
against motion carried
so we'll add that to the bottom of the
agenda which will be Point number 14 now
do we have any other urgently business
no okay let's move on to
Point number six traffic installation
adjustments did the roading manager have
any fresh information he would like to
update
through your worshiper I think hopefully
the my reporters reasonably
comprehensive but really it's a an
update
um after a reasonable period of time
since the
um the first adjustments were done to
the uh to the previous innovative
straights project
but that period of time has shed light
on how the the
um the components that have been that
have remained have been performing and
potentially further adjustments that
need to be made to those remaining
remaining facilities
like for that Murray uh did we have any
questions for Murray
councilor Reed thank you Mr Mia um
Murray just going forward what's
thinking about irk Street I've had a few
comments particularly through the long
hot summer
um where are we at with any improvements
or upgrades to be made
there
it's true worship
um
I'm I'm I haven't been involved with the
with the designers for that project
um
um so I would need to come back to you
and find out and come back to you on
that issue
okay
uh councilor Phillips
uh thank you worship
um just in item three on Wigan Street
Barry Street intersection
I've had a a reasonable amount of
conversation with the people that live
in Wigan Street
um
and some of them have been there for a
long time
physically forget that the giveaway sign
even though there are a they are the
largest giveaway signs you can possibly
get
continually forget about it and drive
straight through
so
um just the
item about the effective solution could
be in a roundabout I think that you're
probably better off to to pursue that
one
and um
see how the transport industry because I
know that they use that corner and
Street a lot
um how that would how that would go
and I would probably prefer a roundabout
rather than a give or stop wastelands on
either of those corners
yep through your worship um yes that
that's basically what I'm
um suggesting or recommending in my
report
um the their intersection really does
lend itself to a roundabout solution
because uh it's it's very wide both both
um both roads approaching the
intersection are wide so it allows
enough room to
um put on one of the roundabouts that
particularly a small diameter one one
that can be run over in those situations
where
um big loads have to be diverted down
there which does happen on occasions and
I mentioned in my report the rail crash
on on a roll Crossing in mersey Street
about a year ago where we had to make
some
urgent adjustments to the the
um previously installed Furniture in the
middle of the night
um but around about I think would help
traffic flow there but it would also
help help slow traffic down on that long
straight wagon street without
unfairly penalizing
anyone really
sorry could I just add a comment to that
as well as the intention to move if we
were to remove the roundabout from crew
Street to move it there if it was
successful
uh through your worship yeah that that's
exactly what um I think we uh should do
um that would obviously uh minimize the
cost of of um putting that solution in
place
thank you Murray I think it Council uh
councilor I mean councilor Dixon
I am a frequent user of the roundabout
at crew Street and artwork Street
and there's considerable confusion
um as to the way that it operates I
guess point one is we actually need some
education on the way that the smaller
roundabouts are supposed to work now
there is a lot of misunderstanding in
between people driving over them quite
regularly and give way doesn't apply in
the case of that roundabout project
that's coming along our wood script
training writing huge Chris
generally
Moscow system
um
for their own safety because the speed
of which vehicles are coming down the
hill so it may well be that we need
addition
need to be looking at rather than just
thank you councilor councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um I'm very pleased to see item one a
new report Murray about equal Street LC
Street in Birch Lane into section
there's been a lot of confusion there in
people complain a lot to me about that
and I think there's been some very close
um missus of having accidents there one
of the things I'm wondering about is the
courtesy Crossings because they're
they're faded but they're still there
and people are really unsure whether
they're still in use or not in use and
it's a wee bit confusing for the public
as well
and also I'm wondering why there's a
stopped sign at around about
it's at Fairfield Street coming in there
there's a new stop sign the at a
roundabout
foreign
markings on the road uh the the signs uh
have remained as giveaway uh
unfortunately it was a a blooper from a
a contractor
um if they're locked up with the seen
the giveaway signs they should have in
seen the the roundabout ahead of them it
should have um uh emphasized the fact
that it should be give way markings
however that that situation has been
addressed um very quickly by a
contractor they accepted they'd made an
error
so the giveaway triangle has been
restored and it's all as it should be
um with that particular intersection
um
yes the the other uh intersection Equal
Street
um Elsie Street really only made sense
uh shifting their priorities to what
they are currently uh when the bottom
end of vehicle street was closed at Main
Street but once that was opened uh as
the public
requested and demanded
um then it really took away any any
sense of of having that priority remain
as it has
um yes
sorry married the courtesy Crossings oh
sorry yeah through the courtesy
Crossings uh We've we've taken away all
of the uh furniture that that that's
accompanied them so the um the uh
temporary curb blocks they've all gone
any
um Gardens I must have met some of them
were just removed this morning uh the
last ones but
um so the only thing that is remaining
there is uh are the markings uh most of
those markings or probably all of them
are wearing out reasonably well
um so uh and and we didn't really have
any plans to to actually
um seal over them or or
um paint them out because I think
they'll continue to wear out quite
quickly now um I I haven't had any
comments from the public that I can
recall
um regarding uh being confused
um but that that should be that should
reduce quite quickly hopefully um now
that everything's gone
councilor Richmond Fair
just just through your worship to uh
obviously the routing manager
um sorry I've got my back to you but in
regard to that list there is that the
list that um
that was the final list that had come
through
uh Eric's Road ad manager when we did
the uh did that final uh review
it was all those just I probably could
do this by phone call but just confirm
that is the final uh sort of review
document that we had that was doing the
corrections yeah from the end of uh
Street's Innovative and Streets Alive
and
through worship
um yet the the items that we've removed
um
were basically all of the items that
um that I was aware of that had been
requested to be removed by by the
counselors and the items that remained
uh were those that the councilors had
requested uh remain in the meantime and
so the the report that I've put in uh is
requesting adjustment to that list of
remaining items that had been agreed by
the councilors
um thanks
um Murray just one more matter in regard
to what councilor readers said
um at the ex at the end of that and in
the review the Oak Street project was
one of the favorable points that came
out and also if we go back prior to
covert uh with the tussa country or the
Country Music Awards Eric Street was
very very popular and they actually used
some of the items that were tied up and
they were actually popular out of
streets of Life there was a stage and
also some areas where busking and bands
took place so I think it's it's quite um
pertinent but what the counselor said
that we probably do need to make sure we
don't lose that in the dust of time or
it goes on the Shelf I don't think we're
going to get it for the snicks one so
but uh thanks
um what one other point to note there is
the
um the changes that are occurring at the
St James Theater
um that I think that has had some
influence on the the uh the delay to to
um progressing uh the what what's
happening in
um in our straight
um
but as I said earlier I'll come back to
the council with more information
thank you councilor councilor Stringer
thank you worship um
in support of mcfarrell's comment there
about the Europe Street
um the seating in the furniture that was
there having spoken to shop owners in
that along there they did experience
um
a little bit more traffic and people
hanging around which made it look a bit
more vibrant in the town that people
would sit and use the seats in the sun
they would certainly unhealthy coffees
and it did make the streets seem more
vibrant thank you
sorry thank you councilor uh
uh councilor Paul mcfarrell
thank you you wish it I'd just like the
um agree with councilor Havel about the
education is a key thing I think one of
the things that we take for granted is
when something's new we really needed to
explain to people what's happening and
take them on the journey as everybody
talks about
and just explain to them what's
happening and why we're doing it and
things like that and I know in the
streets are live they you the council
did try to explain to a lot of people
and a lot of people didn't realize that
but
um I just think they need to educate
them and while we're doing it we can
show the tell them what's on the below
their steering wheel which is an
indicator will be helpful as well
thank you counselor
do we have any further comments I feel
like it's all all agreements with what's
what's proposed but councilman McKinsey
just just a quick comment
um education around roundabouts is
massive because Paul you've seen it
we've all seen it on the mersey street
the amount of people that think they
have the right away when they're on the
state highway
they just drive straight through and
don't even look I don't know what to do
about that personally I think
roundabouts are wonderful things
everywhere but it's just some people
don't get it they're on the main Highway
and I've seen it time and time again
they just drive straight through without
even looking and there's people stuck in
the middle you're going what
what we do about that I don't know
thank you thank you for that Council and
I think there was a recurring theme
around there around education I do
wonder whether it is our responsibility
or it said a letter that we need to
write to what katahi in terms of
um some some further education specific
to our our district I'm I'm not
particularly sure um whether we divide
into that uh Murray and then I think Rex
wants to talk about extreme uh through
worship um yes it is it is definitely a
an issue that we have been thinking
about and considering uh and uh probably
a good vehicle for that education is
through Road Safety Southland which our
council is part of
um so I will be taking that issue to
Road Safety Southland because I'm sure
that it isn't it isn't just Gore drivers
that um need education I think it's sell
The Wider wider wider region so um we'll
be taking that issue to Road Safety
South them
thanks for that Murray yes it's people
coming to the school district and
driving radically rather than our own
reasons I agree
um uh sorry Rex
thank you
um just to help you with the extreme
revitalization project
um
uh
they're like 13 months ago
um started to get involved with the
landscape landscape architect with
regards to
developing or looking at further
developing that concept it's
subsequently been put on hold through to
other matters that have taken priority
both from a organization-wide
perspective but also from a
project-based perspective and I think
with the conversation today it's
certainly an opportunity I actually sent
an email from the Landscape Architects
just last week asking where they were at
or where we were at with it and I said
not anticipating this conversation but
it said that we would like to start
thinking about re redeveloping out or
rebuilding their Pro approach so the
other thing I'd suggest is with the
long-term plan process
starting to get underway in terms of
some identification for what might be
priorities going forward over the next
three to ten years it's certainly a
process that we would encourage you to
incorporate your thinking for that extra
Eric Street Rejuvenation in into that
process as well and rest assured Murray
um while you haven't been involved with
it today and I'm sure you will be
so to move this along because I I think
a lot of this as Rick's alluded to
especially around Eric Street probably
belongs in the long term plan discussion
because I think it's part of a much
bigger picture
um however I do agree with uh councilor
Reed that we should get a bit more of an
update on the Fairfield irk Street
intersection there
um if
uh councilor Dixon sorry instead yep
um if that's okay with with you Murray
yeah cool so with that added to the
recommendations
um so the report we received and the
council approved the following actions
restore the giveaway priority traffic
traveling on Echo Street rather than
Elsie Street remove the roundabout at
the crew Street artwork Street
intersection
T the North ardwick Street approach to
the crew Street intersection in sort of
give whale compulsory stock control on
the North ardwick Straits at the crew
Street intersection and still a painted
right turn Bay on crew Street South of
the new tea intersection with Arbor
Street and investigate the suitability
of a Wigan Street slash bury Street
intersection for the installation of a
roundabout and a range its construction
of suitability
confirmed and an update on the Fairfield
slash Eric Street roundabouts could I
please have a mover for that list of
recommendations councilor nectar now and
the seconder councilor Reed do we have
any further discussion on those actions
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
next up is the point number seven I feel
like we have made a number of
resolutions here today that probably
cover that so if there is no further
discussion I think we move on to point
number eight
thank you councilors
uh Point number eight which is the local
government commission representation
review update uh Ricks would you like to
speak to that
just to say that it'll take the
reporters read and it's more around
information
sharing process or information sharing
opportunity for you from a reasonably
prescriptive process that comes through
the local government commission so happy
to answer any questions but yeah I think
it's self-explanatory in terms of the
report
thank you Rick's uh councilors do we
have any questions
councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um just as part of the amendment and the
terms of reference
I would support a full independent
review of operations and the governance
interface of council
oh we're not doing that are we not doing
number seven no I was just asking before
whether we had any discussion on it we'd
move to point number eight but I can I
can take your your notes down for number
seven if you would like oh thank you the
recommendations that we passed in the
first meeting and also the start of this
one have indicated that we will refresh
them with um our jindin and taitor and
they will help us help us through that
did you want to still comment or well I
would just like to see it at the um at
broader so that it takes in the
governance and the operational interface
because I think what has happened just
recently means that um it's it's really
a fair process for all parties
fits that's my view and I'm sorry I
missed that and we seem to go through
that pretty quickly but
um thank you for noting that no that's
okay Council I'm sorry I flicked through
that quite quickly uh I think based on
uh Council stronger's question to our
presenters today they were looking at
making the scope significantly wider um
as in the effect of do it once and do it
right so
um and at PACE it seems
we're happy to move on to number eight
any further comments
no number eight do we have any questions
for Rick's on that one
thank you I'm happy to move that
recommendation
uh councilor Stringer is the seconder
could I just get clarification on just
that second one there of Rex you weren't
suggesting that we make the appointments
to their independent panel today or were
you looking for recommendations for that
panel today as well no I was looking for
you to support the appointment of an
independent panel I'll come back with a
separate report
um and take over canvas and take on
board your views and preparing that
report as to who might be appropriate
because we try and get wide
representation of community members as
part of that as well and you'll also
note recommendation
um three and four also N5 also require
further further reporting back as well
so it's just more supporting that so it
gives me the direction to then undertake
that to come back to you with a report
thank you for that Rex
do we have any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
next we have the transportation
procurement strategy 2023 would Murray
look to speak to this report at all
uh thank you worship
um yeah so uh as you'll see uh the the
attached uh Transportation procurement
strategy
um as
um before you
um so that this is slightly overdue
um unfortunately changes and and
Personnel
um it's it slips through the cracks
um we've gone through quite a um quite a
process uh both with our
um uh consultant and with uh walker
katahi uh and I must say walk of katahi
where where
um uh were very useful constructive
um and um in assisting us to get to the
strategy that we've got
um the strategy does uh it's basically a
pardon the plan of road map to
procurement of of all of our roading
activities
from Professional Services to physical
work
um
uh without the uh the um strategy or the
the endorsed strategy we're basically uh
we theoretically cannot do any new
um new um procurement which relies on
subsidized funding so it is it is quite
critical that we we do have the endorsed
document
um available to us one of the things
that should be noted is that we we've
taken the approach of
quite a wide approach so that allows us
lots of different options in procuring
the various activities that we do and
that includes a collaboration with with
our neighbors where that is advantageous
to us and that and where they allow us
to do that we have done that in the past
um and that has been
um has proven
acceptable to them and it's been been
quite successful and saved us money
thank you for that marriage do we have
any questions for Murray councilor Garda
yes that was the point I was going I
always like to make through the worship
to Marius
with our seal renewals is there quite
any or a big advantage in collaborating
with their neighbors to try to make it a
bigger danger and a stronger tender
through your wheelchair that's
um
very likely to be the case I'm actually
in discussion with both uh with our two
biggest Neighbors at the moment
um and I think it's the likely path that
we'll take
um one of the potential things that we
may save on is is tender and costs which
can be quite a quite a large large
amount so there are definite advantages
if if we can get everyone to agree
thank you for that Murray and councilor
councilor string and then councilor Reed
thank you worship through Murray a
couple of questions here
um one of them is uh and reporters
talking about the increase of the number
of contracts being awarded to New
Zealand businesses are we using any um
foreign supplies or foreign chain
suppliers
um
the other one is
um and working in regards to the rates
that we're currently putting towards our
roading
um obviously the nzta can have a
contribution amount to it
um would we be worth putting a little
bit more into writing and will that
increase the the effect that
ncta feed back to us
um through your worship um an answer to
the to your first question regarding
offshore businesses doing uh our roading
contracts um
currently we we the the main
um what it might classify is offshore
businesses are more involved in the
physical sorry in the Professional
Services consultancy side of things we
use quite a wide range of Professional
Services Consultants
based on their expertise in particular
areas but
um the likes of Becker and stantec
um
overseas owned businesses that they've
derived though from
businesses that um
that have been purchased from New
Zealand
in the physical Works area
um
no all of the physical Works contractors
that we use which is the vast majority
of our of our expenditure on
um on contractors
uh is uh they're all new zealand-based
some of those particularly downers and
and Fulton Hogan have expanded overseas
but they they started from New Zealand
and
um I think new zealanders probably stole
their their main areas of activity so uh
we the the way we've structured our
contracts
um we've probably maximized the
opportunity for local contractors to to
be involved in it in our work
oh sorry the second point was regarding
um uh additional funding going in or
rates funding going into roading um the
um
the the budgets or the the estimates the
draft estimates that we've um requested
for in for next year's annual plan
do include an increase in
um rates fund or requirement for rates
funding unfortunately uh it's it's more
Treading Water rather than
um making us a a large increase in level
of service
I'm currently in discussion with Walker
katahi regarding
um
getting additional funds or getting a
cost scope adjustment done because we're
still in the the three-year original
three-year cycle where would the next
year's
next financial year will be the the
third year of the three-year cycle
um the three-year funding was agreed to
unseat uh by Walker to katahian at the
start of that cycle but one of the
problems that we do have in waku katahi
do have in
providing us some Assurance as to
whether we can with whether they can
match our increased needs is the other
things that are happening around the
country
there's a big increase in calls for Waka
katahi funding so we are pushing our
Barrow and hopefully we will get at
least some matching of the extra funding
that we're requesting
thank you for that Marion thank you for
that councilor Council Reed you're just
a comment um and then I'm quite happy to
move that recommendation but thanks for
the report Murray it's nice and in-depth
um funnily enough I quite enjoyed the
road and
um conversations
um I will say it's really a pleasure to
read that report and note that local
businesses are given the opportunity to
Tender and are usually very well
received with their pricing I mean that
allows you know employment and financial
benefits to the district and
I think that's a really good positive
move thank you thank you
to move the recommendation thank you
councilor uh
uh while we had to ask for a seconder uh
councilor McDonald cancer Dixon did you
want to speak to that
I just wanted to say
um through your worship Murray I just I
read through this and I can see the
amount of work that you've put into this
policy it's it's quite amazing so
um yeah excellent excellent work and a
very good report thank you
thank you cancer
any further comments
do we all know what we the motion is
yep as it sits
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors
10 Service delivery review for roading
2023 Murray would you like to talk to
this one
uh through your worship um yeah that
this report is very closely associated
with the previous report
an East 17 or section 17 a review is
required of all of our activities at the
frequencies that I've um
indicated in our report
um
we were again overdue for this
e17a review
um but um
we were again assisted by external
parties particularly collaboration with
um with our neighbors
um Southland District Council weren't in
exactly the same position as us and we
we've both
um
um collaborated with a consultant
um who invercargill City had recently
used so
um so it what we expected to be several
months to repair to prepare we were able
to prepare quickly with the consultant
that we used and it
met the requirements of wakukete so um
uh it is part of the the procurement
strategy as well
thank you Murray uh questions counselor
got on
um just for you the chair to Murray the
consultant would be able to only charge
a third then wouldn't he
so sorry what the consultant would be
only better charge a third if he could
shoot it with the three of us
um
through the through your worship um yeah
I think we did get a uh or both of us
got a cap price rate
um with that close corporation
collaboration
thank you for that Murray and councilor
Garden
I think those those are very good
recommendations and I'm glad to hear
that um that we're already in the
process of of making some magic happen
uh by the sounds of things
do we have any further comment
Plus for a mover
cancel Stringer secondary councilor
guard iron do we have any further
discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against motion is carried thank you
councilors
minutes of the matoda community board
meeting
were there any questions arising from
thus I see that we have the chair here
so she may be willing and able to answer
questions if there are any
might just help counselors slightly and
just point to some areas that might be
worth discussion
uh on following a discussion with
councilor Phillips
um yesterday
I think it would be Paramount that we
have a Gore District Council
representative and more importantly the
matone award representative on the
proposed taluk Park stage two project
team
uh did we have something in the the
rounds of a recommendation to the board
um that councilor Phillips be added to
that councilor read
I am happy to move that motion
moved by councilor Reed seconded by
councilor uh mcphail that we will make a
recommendation that uh
so just for procedure
is that appointed by the board or can
Council Council Council can afford that
okay so we can we can add um cancer
Philips names of the list so first and
seconded that we add
cancel the Phillips name to the list I
will put that in particular motion all
those in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried
uh the second one that I pull out is the
point number six around the financial
accounts the board has recommended or
had requested the council provided an
additional ten thousand dollars to the
matoda beautification fund
did we have any discussion around that
councilor Stringer
oh yes sir's worship
um I was just wondering if there was if
that money was e-marked for anything
already in future
I would imagine I'm happy to point to
the CFO on this one but I would imagine
we'd have to find that ten thousand
dollars so we would have to pull it from
a different area yeah
which would be part of the annual plan
process that we're currently going
through
do we feel that it's a discussion for
annual plan uh councilor Phillips
uh thank you the the reason why you
brought this up to attention to the to
the board
was the mere factors that in 1983 when
we first had no funds and we applied to
council for the 20 000 for a
beautification funding
um we stored it up uh and then spent the
money on
several projects within Matera during
that period of time and it we have done
a lot of projects in material over the
years with with this money and
um
I just thinking about the time frame in
1983 it was 20
um 29 000 and now I just think it needs
to be increased
um whether it's a annual plan event I
look I don't think so
um to me it's no different to your
Council approving a grant to any other
organization within Council and I
believe that um
that should be done
it would be totally different if the
board weren't prudent with their money
and didn't and just spend it willy-nilly
but they don't and I think it's
proven over the years but the projects
that's been gone through the board
thanks
thank you councilor good argument uh
councilor mcphail
East three worship just a query to
councilor Phillips so do we know why it
was 20 000 back then like was where did
the amount come from
20 000 was a lot of money in those days
yeah that's what I'm saying it's not
much these days but no
um it was a mere factors that we thought
a five-year a five-year break or in
between a three-year break of term that
we would have enough money to do a major
project within that period of time of
their board so it would have enough
saved up so the ball could do a
reasonable amount of proteins and that
was the reason why
they were just on the on the basis of
what the other counselor our councilor
Phillips is indicating there you know 10
000 does seem very very reasonable to to
be considering And discussing here
thank you councilor councilor Dixon
thank you worship
um I I think it seems such a great
project and it's a good thing to do but
I'm I'm really hesitant to put another
10 000 into a annual plan process in as
councilor Phillips has said I think it
should be part of the the grants that we
consider
during the next term
councilor garden thank you counselor
yeah I think it's probably an issue it
should be brought up for the annual plan
because the 20 000 goes in every year I
presume and we've got 7 950 there now
and um you'd be
um we're looking down the barrel of a
pretty hard annual plan and um we need
to actually discuss it as a whole
as a whole here's the whole budget for
this coming year
thank you councilor counselor
I can see uh Merit and both options that
have been put forward so for me the
question is if we've got a grant fund
available as their 10 000 sitting there
that is able to be used
and the answer is no I'm seeing from
over there I'll relieve um confirm that
please I think
that was a knock
uh councilor Stringer thank you Council
uh through his worship um I think what
council Phillips is trying to say is
that due to inflation over that time
frame has budget has dwindled
um so I think this is probably something
we do have to look at some sort of plan
going forward
thank you
thank you councilor I I guess I'd like
to add and I don't know if this builds
to the point or not but there's quite a
lot of work going on in Matilda now with
the the likes of tullic Park stage two
the the pole being pulled down the
medical hub
I don't know whether an increase in the
beautification fund is would help the
the further development of the of the
community given the amount of money
that's being poured in or whether the
amount of money being poured in as is
the contribution I'm not sure but it's
just food for thought of there are quite
quite high profile projects going in
there but that extra ten thousand
dollars might help make the rest of the
Town beautiful to add to those projects
on
true
I would tend to agree with counselors
around I think it's a bit hard to to
make a fear call without with being
outside of the annual plan discussions
but I do feel for Council Phillips of
wanting to give the board a little bit
of certainty now
um councilor Phillips thank you worship
um
while I like to say uh right here now
that the councils all agree but if it
needs to come to the annual plan that's
fine but I'm putting you on notice all
you counselors that I'm looking for ten
thousand dollars and then you'll be in
thank you
you
the intention is the timelines that I've
seen that you'll be adopting an annual
plan in about six six weeks or seven
weeks so we're talking a six-week period
to have this conversation and to have a
an actual confirmed decision
um and um I I take note of councilor
Phillips putting you on notice and I'm
sure that that will be raised again when
you have your drafting you're playing
conversation on the 20 on the 30th of
this month and then adoption on the 27th
of June so I'm sure it will come to your
table a couple of times yet for ten
thousand dollars
thank you for that Rick so I think just
to move the the conversation on I think
it's just noted at this stage and then
we'll have have that proper discussion
at annual plan
uh the next part I'd like to pull out is
the next one down which is item number
seven uh the only uh cost so the the
recommendation is that uh the deputy
chair Colleen who's with us here today
um
be endorsed to attend the local
government conference in Christchurch
the board is very CL kindly met the
registration cost um and would ask that
the council fund flights and
accommodation
I personally see no issue with that I
think it's a fair deal of
contributions between the council and
also the community board do we have any
further comments around that
no
uh councilor Dixon I was just wondering
if they um if you have any idea of the
the accommodation flights cost
I think it was I think it was ballpark
what was it at the meeting
um
it would probably be around the same
number of that 1500 yeah I would imagine
I was a civil gay event plus plus
flights
counselor Bridgewater just so you
worship we'd obviously um confirmed the
nominations for the
for the attendance of the of the group
so I don't see any issue with us that we
have to we would definitely be with
those flights and accommodation I
support that
thank you Council just the clarification
that would be in addition to Nikki
coming along as well so there would be
three of us past the chief executive as
well
no no changes there fantastic uh let's
move on to number eight which is that
the board requests the writing manager
to invest cleaning the inside curves do
we have any issue with that there's a
council
Awesome Moving on uh the other
recommendation on number nine is that
the gravel flanks be maintained to a
higher standard and graded on a more
regular basis
did the council have an issue with that
at all
no
uh and that the board uh so number 10
now and that the board notes the the
roading manager would formally advise of
the board's request for a permanent
speed reduction uh so that would mean
that the 70k zone that has been
temporary as you're coming into matoto
would become permanent
no issue there either oh cancel the
Stringer
uh yeah through worship um I just noted
there were
there were two respondents or two people
that spoke to it yeah two emails that
were supportive of it have we had any
feedback on the onto the contrary from
people there at all
a straight through worship
um not to my knowledge I don't think
there's been any negative um feedback to
that
thank you councilor look uh Nikki you
wanted to speak to that
since so both ends so would include the
entry to to Matata as well
which would be a new addition I believe
yes
no issues with that
fantastic I will leave those as they are
could I please get a move that the
minutes be received and that the
recommendations contained in the minutes
be ratified councilor Dixon seconded by
councilor Phillips I will put the motion
all those oh cancel the guardian
you want the 10 000 to be changed uh
the only one that would really be
changed is number five we would we're
just adding councilor Phillips we've
pulled that out as as separate
or would you like to change the wording
of the the number six
yes we can we can change that
recommendation that will come to the
annual plan process
so we'll make that slight change did you
get that Susan so Point number Point
number five that's the addition of um
Council Phillips and point number six
it's that that recommendation yeah
considered as part of the annual plan
uh so I had a mover and a second uh do
we have any further conversation
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you counselors
and thank you community board
James community center and
library development project update did
you have anything to add there x no no
just in the absence of the chief
executive reporters read and um
I think it's reasonably self-explanatory
thank you uh credit mover that the
report be received
councilor read second of I cancel the
Stringer do we have any discussion
councilor Phillips
I just think congratulations all around
I required you where is it and yeah
we get a building setting next door to
us for that caliber for that money that
we spend I think it's been
a very very worthwhile project
thank you councilors and I don't know
about the rest of the elected members
but I've definitely had positive
feedback from the entire Community
around the use of it councilor read
um only a comment and probably
irrelevant the big scheme of things but
recently been told of two people from
one from the North Island one from the
south island who are here for a family
gathering the wet cold day they didn't
know what to do
they'd already had a coffee and a meal
so they actually came to the library
in one one way and one went the other
and they were there for two hours they
really enjoyed this day and commented on
what a fantastic facility it was so I
thought that was quite positive
it's a lovely story thank you thank you
councilor councilman Kinsey
just a quick comment as well I had a
text from a listener that had been there
from out of town I just wanted to
comment on your beautiful library and
that was the that was the text but you
know it's it's great feedback
thank you councilor
uh I will move us on uh I will put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried
number 13 is the summary of the mural
Forum I wasn't there for most of it I
was only there for the beginning of it
um to counselor Val want to speak to
this isn't the most recent one it's the
one beforehand just for clarification
do we have any questions from elected
members
dated now but yep
uh could I just have a movie that the
report be received
councilor Max and a secondary Council
haval all those in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
last up we just have that
urgent item
so hopefully councilors and staff are
now slightly more familiar with it uh
the grant I've just calculated the
numbers during the meeting the grant
currently sits at
3640 per year
uh I would suggest and this is just off
the top of my head
um that we double it I think that's a
fair assessment which would bring us to
7280 per year
um this is a grant that the um the
Bowling Club is is not our employees
um so it works like
any other Grant just for clarification
and I believe that Jason may be happy
answering questions of
putting him under the in the spotlight
uh if Cancer's had any councilor Jackson
thank you worship can I just ask you
Jason is it really important for the
transfer station to be open on the
Sunday and for such for five hours
or could it be
two hours perhaps on a Sunday
save some funding yeah I might just see
if New York can uh field that one for me
but um hopefully we can get some
feedback
uh yeah thank you through your worship
the
material has managed with the Staffing
that it's had but I I see in the later
they're talking about two people there
at a time I'm told often there's only
one person
and also
if it has been looked at to move forward
there needs to be some membrane of
understanding of what is expected of
them
we've just shifted all the whiteware
from there and a lot of that had to
go over the tip face because there was
so much other rubbish mixed in with it
the skip truck does a weekly pickup for
me to bring the General Rubber shop to
gore and he's often only bringing up
half skips but there's two half skips
rather than a full skip
there's no management actually being
done and once the person goes through
the gate
that may be a bit harsh on me saying but
that's what I observe and there's stuff
dumped at the gate
could be there on a Thursday Friday but
it's still there on the Monday Tuesday
and I have to get contractors in once
that builds up
so there probably hasn't been much
oversight
with the agreement that was with the
Bowling Club and I'm not sure what the
agreement actually was but um
it
technically it is not called a transfer
station and material under them for the
ministry for environment since they
brought in the white slaves
so we've removed it off that and it's
basically a collection point and the
reason for that was anything that
restored
um we could be liable for a levy as it
goes into material and then another Levy
as it's transported that score
but one of the conditions of taking that
off the the database of a transfer
station was that we are not allowed to
store anything on site which was scrap
metal so that's therefore we've had to
clean up that
here
thank you for that Mario councilor
Phillips
sorry thank you Neil
councilor put
ah thank you I'll probably put a little
bit of light on the on the subject
probably
um
when this when we uh the the transfer
sorry the collection point now was uh
shut as is a as a landfill
we had to have some sort of
point for the local residents to go to
and
remove their rubbish
the people that have green waste etc etc
right so it was muted by the community
board at the time and I was one that we
approach a local
um
organization who wanted to look after
the trip to well so-called transfer
station then and use it as a fundraising
activity
this year
well last year things started to go a
little bit Wayward as as
Neo would just explained and we did have
a a meeting with
the current Bowling Club
uh pointing out our disappointing
interviews and we did change a few
aspects
but I look at the point that they're
looking to stopping this
current
job that they're doing for us at the
moment
if the transfer station was to shut
because of the lack of people wanting to
go in there yeah because they could go
in there I can guarantee that it's going
to cost you more than seven thousand
dollars with the amount of flight
tipping to remove from the from the
material transfer station
so I would just like to recommend that
um seriously think about
um putting up what you know the what
you've suggested the cost suggestion
but also have a more firmer
um talk with them on the aspect of what
you expect them to do right we don't
expect
having
the rubbish still left on a Sunday
afternoon at the at the gate we expect
it to be put in the containers etc etc
um and I think it could be it could be
that uh
that maybe seven thousand eight hundred
is eight or seven thousand and eighty
dollars might not be enough
we could probably put it up to maybe
seven five
and then have the definite terms of
reference of saying that okay the bins
must be completely looked at filled up
properly before another one is filled in
to stop half transfer estate half the
bins
and all the bins being removed only half
full
etc etc so you fill one before you
refill the other
and and that way then I think it's um
getting to the point where our money
that we're going to be spending could be
saving in the long term
just like
until we
and I think we're about I don't know six
seven months away from having a proper
talk about what we're going to do with
Matera and in the meantime I think we
just need to
sort of appease them a little bit
and I am mindful of what I've said in
the leader I did put my apology I just
did not show up there was a bit naughty
of them but um
yeah I
I like to think that we
are putting our hand out a little bit to
them until such time as we really know
what we're doing
nothing that we need to do we nearly
need to do that
thank you councilor Council mcfarl
I think you worship
um just thinking about that I'm just
looking at it from perhaps a club of
society looking from the other direction
they may think a bit disgruntled because
they're not being paid enough to do a
job and it's a possibility on the other
side of it as a council we're trying to
work with waste management at the moment
and trying to
Show an example of what we want to do to
lessen that load and do a good job I
think
working with them is a definite
advantage in the meantime so I wouldn't
be too worried about I think paying them
some more is a good idea as a as a good
representative of the district thank you
thank you councilor my suggest a
recommendation from what I'm hearing
because coming back to it's a very
similar situation to what we headed with
the with the borders this needs to come
back to annual plan discussions while we
can indicate that we're going to do it
needs to come attend your plan that
might give a decent time frame for Neil
and or Jason to have that conversation
around a memorandum of understanding in
line with with that
um
Jason
possibly but that's a pretty short time
frame we've got a fair bit to work
through with this annual plan but I
think
I think to for the sake of the meeting I
think if we can
um
work on it on that basis and consider it
as part of the annual plan that then
allows
um myself and Neil we can work with the
the
um with the Bowling Club and just
establish that those rules and as
councilor Phillips pointed out there's a
longer term conversation here that needs
to go into our long-term plan process
which is in the coming months just
around again uh the full service or the
full
um
uh value chain of of waste throughout
the district and where we need to make
improvements versus uh in inefficiencies
so I think that's part of that bigger
conversation
thank you Jason well said uh would I be
able to then just to move this along
um get a mover that we
um will consider doubling the rates
um from 70 per week to 140 per week as
part of the annual plan discussions and
that uh
conversations are starting to be had
around a memorandum of understanding
with the Bowling Club and transfer
station
councilor Phillips happy to move there
councilor McDonald happy to second that
do we have any further discussion on
that topic councilor Reed sorry I'll
make a quick
is there any cost to actually
um
leaving their rubbish at material I mean
we pay in Gore when we go through the
transfer station is there any do they
have to pay for
that or is it gratis
three you worship the
there is a cost to the resident when
they take it out of
two on their Sunday or Sunday but it's a
ballpark figure because there's no
scales
but we are reliant on what is
delivered to the office
following Monday I think it is from that
kiosk so there's no real record keeping
in such azulane
there's no real record keeping from the
material yep
uh you worship y'all um
but interested to hear that there's no
record keeping it it um
they they take number plates uh of re of
the residents uh they come in and they
also take um
a list of monies going uh in what they
what they estimate to go in yeah and so
on and and that was part of the
discussion in the middle of last year
when they were getting a little bit uh
lapsy Daisy and we had a discussion
about they should be doing a bit more
control but if they're not if they're
not doing that again
I think we need to have a little bit of
a heavy stick
my comment there was that I
now that you say that I'm unaware of any
record keeping and I don't know if Jason
is either
no just I think we'll follow that up
we'll just uh confirm that come back um
and we can bring it that's maybe some of
the Cameron back as part of the annual
plan discussions but again if we're
going to be establishing a new set of
criteria with them around that we'll
certainly
um refine that for the for the next year
thank you for that I wonder sorry I'm
going to slow this down again but I
wonder if it's actually an issue for the
community board um might be worth more
their time than full councils but
just a bit more of a focused effort
just given the problems or councilor
Phillips
I think we could play get to the
community woman
um
you Worship in and just get them to put
it on the agenda for discussion then
um
they may have some answers to bring
forward to council but in the meantime
let's just get on and with what we're
discussed here today and and uh carry on
with what Jason's trying to do because
he can bring reports to the community
board as well and together we're going
to talk this out
I think that we leave it up to the
interpretation of the staff as to which
which um
group it goes to
so we have a mover and a seconder uh do
we have any further discussion
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried thank
you counselors
that brings us to the end of the public
session we will have a little bit of a
break maybe a five minute break and
between